[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: The piñata is a
colorful paper mache object
typically filled with
candy or small toys, then
suspended high from a string.
Blindfolded partiers take
turns trying to hit the piñata
with a stick to break
it open and release
a shower of goodies.
From popular cartoon characters
to colorful, glittery shapes,
today's piñatas are a
big hit at kids' parties,
where children eagerly
await the decisive
blow that breaks
open the piñata,
releasing the treats inside.
The traditional way to build
one starts with a clay pot
suspended from a string.
The piñata maker
glues cardboard shapes
to it and secures them by
gluing on pieces of newspaper.
Then she covers the
rest of the pot.
When the glue dries, she
decorates the surface
with colorful paper.
The modern method is to use a
balloon instead of a clay pot.
After inflating the balloon,
she pastes pieces of newspaper
all over it.
This technique is
known as paper maché.
The trick is to
completely saturate
the newspaper with a
thick paste and make
sure no part of the
balloon is left uncovered.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
She continues this
process until she's
built up two or three
even layers of newspaper
all over the balloon.
Then she suspends it from
a clothes pin to dry.
Hours later, the paper mache
is hardened into a shell
around the balloon, which
she now breaks and removes.
Next, she cuts an opening
at the top of the shell.
This is the hole through
which the buyer will
fill the pinata with treats.
She'll later reattach the
cut piece to make a trapdoor.
But first, with the sharp
tips of her scissors,
she pierces a row of holes
along the circumference
and threads twine through them.
She leaves long
ends at the top with
which to suspend the piñata.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This piñata will be star-shaped.
To make each point, she rolls
thin cardboard into a cone,
taping it closed.
She trims it to
the required size,
then cuts tabs at the
base and bends them back.
She makes seven of
these cardboard points,
then tapes them onto
the shell one by one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Once all seven are
positioned, the decorating
with colorful, glittery foil
wrapping paper can begin.
She tapes a sheet around
each point of the star,
then she applies glue
in between the points
and adheres pieces of
wrapping paper to those areas.
She folds other pieces
into flower shapes
and glues them on as well.
Once the entire
piñata is covered,
she tapes matching streamers
to the end of each point.
Historians believe Spanish
missionaries used star piñatas
like this one to convert the
Native peoples in the Americas
to Christianity.
The star symbolized
Satan, its seven points
the seven deadly sins, its
beautiful colors temptation.
Wearing a blindfold
represented blind faith in God.
Striking the piñata with
a stick meant goodness
and virtue battling evil.
Breaking the piñata, releasing
a shower of treats or trinkets,
symbolized heavenly rewards.
[MUSIC PLAYING]